k
[Música]
Olá meus amigos minhas amigas sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma
live Vamos responder as suas dúvidas
antes da gente continuar conforme vocês
forem entrando por favor me deem o
feedback se o áudio está legal por
enquanto não vejo nenhuma mensagem então
se tiver alguém ao vivo por favor dê um
alô dê uma boa noite paraa gente checar
se realmente estamos com o áudio
adequado
bem mas antes de tudo eu vou dividir a
tela com vocês Alexandre já está ao vivo
Boa noite
Alexandre Você está me ouvindo bem o
áudio está legal me dê o feedback por
favor castelani também Fernando
castelani gauziski som está bom Beleza
Muito obrigado bem vamos lá então
responder as
perguntas Dea dividir a tela com você
eu acho que esse formato aqui ficou
melhor
pronto tentar tirar da frente não dá
para tirar assim ao
vivo acho que pode até aumentar um
pouquinho aqui a o
tamanho disso aqui pronto Fica mais
fácil de ler
tão conseguindo ler bem
não Boa
noite Maria Helena também tá ao
vivo primeira pergunta é verdade que o
uso de metiformina e vitamina e
atrapalham absorção do Deia em caso de
[Música]
reposição telefone tocou aqui bem Vamos
responder essa pergunta bem a interação
entre a metiformina vitamina E e
absorção de ideia não tá totalmente
ainda Claro na literatura que elas
realmente acontecem tá
a metiformina você sabe que é um
medicamento para diabetes é na verdade
um fitoterápico é extraído do lilá
francês foi vendido como fármaco mas é
um
fitoterápico ele atua tanto a nível
intestinal quanto a
nível no fígado para regular a Glicemia
tem vários mecanismos de ação para
regular a Glicemia né o tanto de açúcar
no sangue ele também aumenta a
sensibilidade
insulina e ele também foi estudado com
medicação antienvelhecimento
justamente pelo fato de ser
antiinflamatório n é um mecanismo
secundário de ação da metiformina a
porer aumentar a MPK que é uma viha
bioquímica que preserva a longevidade e
também tem uma ação nas CTU innas mas
não há evidências ainda diretas que ele
interfere na absorção de hormônios como
é o caso do dhea tá que é o
dehidroepiandrosterona também conhecida
como
prasterona a vitamina E vocês sabem que
é uma vitamina lipossolúvel e também ela
piposs solúvel ela vai bem com gordura
e os hormônios esteroides também são
hormônios derivados do colesterol que é
um líp então tanto os hormônios
esteroides quanto as gorduras e quanto o
colesterol eles têm afinidade Química
pelo fato de todos serem lipossolúveis
Ok então
ah Até onde eu sei a vitamina E também
não atrapalha a absorção de hormônios
esteroides seria bom viu Eliane Se você
pudesse dizer qual foi a fonte que você
consultou para chegar a essas conclusões
aí porque realmente eu fiquei um pouco
intrigado com essa sua pergunta não
tinha visto isso ainda tá mas eu dei uma
pesquisada e até onde eu pude perceber
não é o fato que a meforma e a vitamina
A atrapalha absorção do Deia OK Até
porque eu passo metiformina aí pros
pacientes e não tenho visto isso na
prática Mas se você puder me me indicar
a fonte que você viu ISO isso seria
interessante tá mas voltando a udia né
idd epi androsterona né Ele é um
hormônio é um esteroide ele vem do
colesterol como todos os hormones
esteroides ele é sintetizado na cortical
das
adrenais ele é convertido Depois de
várias etapas bioquímicas né a udia né
udia na verdade ele vem da primeiro a o
colesterol vira pregnenolona depois de
pregnenolona ele vira e de um lado ele
vira progesterona e pro outro lado ele
vira e a androstenediona e de
androstenediona ele vira Dea ou
dehidroepiandrosterona depois ele vira
testosterona e pode virar estradiol pode
virar estriol E estrona então a absorção
do
Deia depende principalmente da Saúde
intestinal e ele é como ele é um
hormônio esteroide ele também tá
associado às gorduras né Ass como a
vitamina E a presença de gorduras na
dieta vai favorecer a sua absorção
porque ele é lipossolúvel também tá E
também vai depender da função do
fígado embora a vitamina E possa modular
processo de oxidação ele é uma vitamina
e é uma vitamina antioxidante
especialmente os tocotrienóis né que
difundem mais facilmente pela barreira
celular não tem indícios de que a
vitamina E vai atrapalhar a
disponibilidade do Deia tá então essa
aqui é minha resposta para você Liane se
você tiver ao vivo e quiser
complementar me dizer onde você viu essa
informação seria interessante
tá boa noite também Denise que eu não
dei ainda boa noite boa noite
Eliane próxima
pergunta Faz muitos anos que eu tenho
problema de inflamação nos tendões de
Aquiles
sempre que acelero um pouco a velocidade
da caminhada caminho meia hora todos os
dias alongando antes de aquecer faço
alongamentos de yoga quatro vezes por
semana para fortalecer minha pergunta
qual é o tipo de profissional de saúde
mais indicado PR inflamação de tendão de
aquil certo seria um fisioterapeuta
esportivo ou um médico especialista em
tratar causas de inflamação Então nesse
caso aqui no meu entendimento tá deixa
eu ver quem fez a pergunta foi o Roberto
Airosa acho que ele nem tá ao vivo né no
meu entendimento o que acontece aqui não
é nem tanto a especialidade da pessoa tá
eh o que é mais importante aqui é a
maneira como essa pessoa enxerga a o
organismo então você pode tanto procurar
um
fisiatra pode procurar um ortopedista ou
pode procurar um médico como eu que é um
médico hoje que apesar de eu ter
especialidade hoje eu sou mais
generalista do que especialista então é
a visão tá se você conseguir achar um
ortopedista integrativo que não tá louco
para te operar
eh é uma boa alternativa fisiatra que
tem muito menos no mercado também é uma
boa alternativa ou mesmo reumatologista
que tem a visão integrativa também pode
tratar então é menos a especialidade e
mais a abordagem desse profissional
certo então o fisioterapeuta esportivo
eh ele vai entrar em qualquer
circunstância aí Tá ele não vai te
atender sozinho tá porque precisa também
de um médico mas ele é o profissional
mais indicado paraa reabilitação porque
ele que vai te passar a fisioterapia
para recuperação então eu tive por
exemplo uma facete plantar e o
fisioterapeuta foi muito importante na
minha recuperação Apesar de que eh eu
tive que tomar antiinflamatório natural
eu tive que fazer um monte de coisa mas
o fisioterapeuta foi muito importante tá
na no meu recuperação então o
fisioterapeuta ele vai avaliar o quê a
biomecânica a força muscular os padrões
de movimento ele vai identificar
possíveis desequilíbrios né na nas
musculaturas na relação entre os
músculos que vão contribuir para a
inflamação e ele também vai prescrever
exercícios específicos para fortalecer e
melhorar a mobilidade Ok então tem que
ter
o médico que pode ser essas três opções
que eu falei até quatro né seria
fisiatra e ou ortopedista ou reumato ou
até o médico geral né junto com esse
fisioterapeuta esportivo esportivo não
preca necessariamente ser esportivo Mas
seria bom que fosse Sim já que
aparentemente o teu caso aí tá
relacionado a esportes
né e é muito bom que você faça
alongamento é muito bom que se você faça
yoga tá de parabéns por isso viu
Roberto agora vamos falar um pouquinho
você pode usar antinflamatórios naturais
que vai ajudar cúrcuma bosua serrata
eh canela de velho eh garra do diabo
palmitoil etan lamino pea msm tudo isso
ajuda tá e também
eh abordagens mais de locais assim você
pode por exemplo a usar um gel de babosa
na lesão você pode usar um msm local
também Desculpa não msm o dmso local né
tópico você pode usar Aroeira capin
cidreira tem várias opções aí
interessantes Tá mas o mais importante
realmente é você fazer a fisioterapia
correta para alongar né o o tendão
geralmente essas inflamações estão
relacionados a en cortamento tá então
alongar esse tendões aí e então tem que
ser uma abordagem aí multifatorial
beleza se tiver ao vivo também pode se
manifestar Beleza boa noite também
blanders e boa noite Manuel que eu acho
que não cumprimentei vocês
ainda próxima pergunta O Senhor conhece
o teste de soro sanguíneo para fungos e
micotoxinas Dr Andrew campb para
recomendar se é bom vi uma entrevista
dele no canal Dr Michael rusel e segundo
ele as ervas e suplementos usados por
vários médicos para tratar infecção
fungica não são suficientes além da
alimentação e tudo mais ele diz que o
único tratamento eficaz é o tratamento
medicamentoso itraconazol ou
Fluconazol Hum entendi então isso é uma
brigalhada na
literatura Tem muita gente que acha que
o exame indicado para identificar
micotoxinas é o exame de urina tá tem
dois Laboratórios americanos que fazem
esse exame o Real Time Labs e
o great ples Eu acho que o génova não tá
fazendo esse exame até onde eu me lembro
e de
sangue até onde estudei esse assunto não
era um exame mais indicado para toxinas
tá porque as micotoxinas elas são
parecidas
com os metais no sentido de que elas se
acumulam nos tecidos elas não ficam
simplesmente no sangue e essa afirmação
de que o Fluconazol itraconazol seriam
os únicos
tratamentos Eu discordo até porque tem
muito fungo hoje em dia que é resistente
tá
a a esses agentes é muito comum
resistência Fluconazol itraconazol até
terbin asol também terbinafina Desculpa
terbinafina então eu não concordo eu
acho que a base de tratamento tem que
ser e o uso de quelantes de micotoxinas
e utilizar os antifúngicos sim mas não
só os antifúngicos
eh medicamentosos tá você tem que usar
também os naturais por conta da
Resistência fúngica que tem que é bem
comum tá não quer dizer que não vai usar
Fluconazol não quer dizer que não vai
usar
itraconazol mas não é o único tratamento
eficaz não no meu entendimento
tá
então existe várias substâncias vários
eh plantas que T efeito
antifúngico Então a gente tem que
associar as estratégias inclusive usar
Nistatina que Nistatina é é
relativamente Fraco mas a toxicidade
dela é baixa ao contrário do Fluconazol
hidroconazol que dão problemas aí com
fígado com frequência fazer um detox
hepático importante então usar os biters
né que são as ervas amargas né como é o
caso da ALCA chofra é o caso do Boldo é
o caso
né dessas plantas que T essas
propriedades o capin cidreira eucalipto
então são substâncias naturais que TM
propriedades
antifúngicas e vão ajudar também tá além
dos quelantes que são muito importantes
né são para aquilar as toxinas do do
mofo e tem também o uso aí de
antifúngicos no nariz para quem tem
evidência que tem
Eh esses fungos nas cavidades paranasais
né nas cavidades do seios paranasais
utilizar o produto nasal se utiliza
muito o vip nasal é muito usado nos
Estados Unidos no Brasil é difícil acho
que eu nunca vi ninguém
usando
então tem também o alho tem também a uva
urce tem também o orégano tem ações
antifúngicas modificação de estilo de
vida é muito importante cortando o
açúcar reduzindo o estresse
tá o itraconazol como eu falei o
Fluconazol tem o seu papel sim mas eu
não diria que só eles resolvem que tem
que ficar utilizando somente eles
tá então tem casos e casos tem casos
mais leve inclusive que os antifúngicos
naturais vão resolver sem precisar
entrar com Fluconazol e itraconazol e
mais importante que esquei de falar el
tem que sair do ambiente que tem a
contaminação por mofo então mora numa
casa que tem infiltração tem que
resolver infiltração e se não conseguir
resolver infiltração muitas vezes tem
que se mudar de casa tá isso é
fundamental para as pessoas
melhorarem próxima
pergunta existe alguma relação entre
vontade ou urgência para urinar e
desconforto
gástrico pergunta curiosa também
né mas a resposta é
sim a relação entre vontade frequente de
urinar e desconforto gástrico que que
ambos
podem ser causados por fatores
emocionais
estresse inflamação sistêmica em alguns
casos também pode dar sintoma nesses
dois órgãos existe uma comunicação entre
as mucosas né o sistema malte sistema G
da mucosa urinária tem comunicação com a
mucosa gastrointestinal então microbioma
alterado dessas duas mucosas podem se
comunicar
tem pessoas por exemplo especialmente
mulheres que têm infecções urinárias de
repetição que tê problemas de flora
intestinal que tem e microbioma ruim
intestinal e esse microbioma ruim muitas
vezes com excesso de Cândida e de outras
bactérias patogênicas pode eh aumentar
muito o risco de cistite né de infecção
urinária nessas mulheres
pessoas que TM diabetes não controlado
que o açúcar do sangue sumiu muito
também existe a questão de ter
gastroparesia o estômago ele tem
movimento muito mais dificultado né por
conta da lesão neuronal do diabetes e
também vai aumentar o açúcar na urina
Então vai aumentar tanto problemas
intestinais E gástricos como vai ter
problema também de infecção
urinária pessoas que têm diabetes também
pode ter problemas neurológicos a
neuropatia diabética isso vai afetar a
sensação de urgência causando mais
urgência urinária e também pode eh como
eu falei dar gastop paresia e atrapalhar
a digestão e isso causar
sintomas outra coisa Muitas pessoas têm
sensibilidade à cafeína e tem
sensibilidade também a pimenta e esses
dois agentes podem tanto irritar o
estômago Como pode irritar a urina tem
pessoas que toma Pimenta e
ah a capsaicina da pimenta vai parar lá
na urina e a Rita bexiga né então tem
essa relação também né em relação à
sensibilidades alimentares seja pela
Pimenta pela cafeína do café o álcool
também pode causar isso e alguns
alimentos ácidos também
tá então entre as recomendações
que eu faço é que sempre avalie o
organismo como um todo não aceite hoje
ser avaliado de maneira
setorizada de maneira
compartimentalizada é muito importante
ter visão global de tudo fazer exames
Gerais exam de urina junto com exam de
função gastrointestinal se for o caso
avaliação do estômago e do oden e
jejuno e também o esôfago com endoscopia
digestiva alta eh testes também Gerais
de sangue como eu já comentei e sempre
tá avaliando a parte do estresse que
hoje quase todo mundo tem e que vai
desencadear esses sintomas tão comuns
que são dos mais prevalentes do
consultório que é sintomas gástricos e
sintomas urinários
Ok então é isso próxima pergunta tenho
36 anos
Existe alguma contraindicação o risco de
usar Ortiga de oica para queda de cabelo
bem eu preferiria utilizar o sal pometo
tá não que tá errado usar o Tiga de o
que ela também tem uma ação bloqueadora
do DHT né ela tem
ação de bloquear enzima 5 Alfa redutase
porém a ortiga dioica
ela não é o principal para esse tipo de
coisa seria só palmeto mesmo
tá mas ela não tá errado como eu falei
tanto pela ação bloqueadora da enzima
quanto pelas suas propriedades
antiinflamatórias e antioxidantes que
vão ajudar a melhorar a circulação do
couro cabeludo só tem que tomar um certo
cuidado porque tem algumas pessoas que
têm reações alérgicas a Ortiga de oica
ele pode irritar a pele em pessoas
sensíveis especialmente se usar tópico
na no couro cabeludo eh como sempre
mulheres grávidas e amamentando não
devem
utilizar no caso específico do da altig
dioica ela pode estimular o útero né a
contrações e levar aborto espontâneo em
mulheres grávidas então é bem importante
que não se tome na
gestação pessoas que TM o rim fraco sufí
renal tem que tomar cuidado porque ele
pode agravar a situação né A altig
dióica pode sobrecarregar os rins e
também a Tig dióica pode interagir com
anticoagulantes como é o caso da
varfarina e
diuréticos isso pode aumentar o risco de
sangramento quem toma esses remédios tá
ou quem tomar o diurético pode ter
problemas aí eh de perder eletrólitos na
urina Beleza então pode ser utilizado
sim mas eu utilizaria mais o sal palmeto
para essa
atividade TCM do Óleo de coco né TCM o
MCT que é a mesma coisa a pergunta é
aumenta o
colesterol Boa pergunta sim ele
aumenta o HDL colesterol mas também
aumenta o LDL colesterol mas vai
aumentar mais o HDL do que LDL mas
aumenta sim o colesterol
né então eu te digo que sim mas
geralmente o efeito do TCM é positivo
porque ele aumenta mais o HDL do que
aumenta
Ah o LDL em si e como é uma gordura de
cadeia média ele não é acumulado no
organismo como é o caso das cadeias de
cadeia longa que vão virar gordura
corporal né Então as as as gorduras de
cadeia média geralmente elas são
queimadas mais
rápido então elas não têm esse efeito de
afetar demais aí a questão de saúde pelo
contrário né Elas ajudam a aumentar os
copos cetônicos ajuda a melhorar a
fluidez a rapidez de raciocínio então eu
não deixaria de utilizar por conta dessa
desse receio aí que você tá tendo com
colesterol tá
a tem essa pergunta da vacina Eu acho
que eu já respondi essa pergunta no
passado
tá mas vamos lá essa vacina aí que fo
mencionada Kid denga ela é uma vacina
que é direcionada às arboviroses né que
são as doenças virais transmitidas por
mosquito da classe da dengue zica
chicungunha e febre amarela Ela ainda tá
em fase de desenvolvimento fase de
estudos não tem até o momento dados
conclusivos de segurança e eficácia
então ainda tem poucos dados aqui para
falar sobre essa vacina eu não tomaria a
princípio Ok olha que eu tive dengue Ano
passado tive dengue março do ano passado
e fiquei uma semana aí de
cama então eu acho que o mais importante
é a prevenção das doenças através do
controle do vetor que é o mosquito
certo e também tá deixando o seu sistema
imune inteiro com as medidas que a gente
fala aqui né com própolis Vitamina C com
zinco vitamina D
ah vitamina e antioxidantes de forma
geral cúrcuma né então usar os
repelentes naturais como o caso do Óleo
de cintronela capin cidreira tem um
repelente que tava sendo desenvolvido
que era feito com Urucum eu não sei se
ele tá perto de ser
lançado então eu a princípio não tomaria
essa vacina tá quem fez essa pergunta
foi a joelita ou ru Elita não sei como é
que ela gosta de pronunciar se é o
pronúncia em espanhol em português mas
essa que é minha resposta para
eh
ah que o blandon tá comentando o blandon
deixa eu te contar aqui que aconteceu
aqui esse toque do do celular é uma
piada na verdade entendeu E essa
musiquinha o sangue de Jesus tem poder
tá eh novamente eu sou cristão tá eu
respeito demais a fé tanto católica
quanto eh a fé protestante né a fé
evangélica Só que essa musiquinha é uma
musiquinha que eu acho muito engraçada
então toda vez que vem um toque de um
número que não tem nada a ver esse
pessoal enchendo saco aí de
telemarketing e tudo eu coloco essa
musiquinha para eu dar uma risada tá
porque eu acho ela engraçada né É por
isso viu que você ouviu o toque do
telefone é dessa forma aí
então próxima pergunta em qual situação
é indicado a beberina à noite após
jantar e antes de dormir eh não A
beberina tá você tá perguntando
especificamente à noite né Então nesse
horário seria logo após o jantar tá bom
é bom que a beberina você tome ele logo
depois de alguma refeição Então seria
logo após o o
jantar mas não tá errado tomar antes de
dormir não tá Mas seria mais adequado
tomar logo depois de jantar Lembrando
que a beberina é uma metiformina
eh digamos assim melhorada além dela
agir baixando o açúcar do sangue os
triglicérides ela também atua como
tratamento de infecções
intestinais ela tem efeito
antibacteriano ela pode ser usada para
tratamento de diarreia ou desinteria por
causa da sua ação
antimicrobiana e a o efeito dela à noite
é levemente sedativo que ajuda a
descansar à noite
tá então é isso Qual a relação entre a
vitamina D e o pth tem uma relação
direta eu já vou explicar é correto
afirmar que pth alto é sinal de vitamina
D baixa sim e não tá sim e não nem
sempre o paratormônio alto É porque a
vitamina D está baixa mas tem uma
relação sim tá quando você vê que o
paratormônio tá alto tem que desconfiar
da vitamina D baixa e vice-versa
tá E essa relação inversa é porque a
vitamina D ela é importante para
absorção de de cálcio no intestino e
quando o organismo tá com falta de
vitamina del ele compensa aumentando o
paratormônio tá por isso que acontece
essa relação inversa então é como se o
paratormônio fosse um backup do
organismo pra vitamina D que não tá
disponível né por isso que tem essa
relação
inversa mas tem outras causas para para
pth Alto Às vezes a vitamina D tá boa e
o paratormônio tá alto porque tem uma
situação chama-se hiperparatiroidismo
primário tá então isso é pode ser uma
doença nas
glândulas da paratireoide né que são
aquelas glândulas pequenininhas que
ficam atrás da tireoide E aí é um
tumorzinho que produz paratormônio e dá
o hiperparatiroidismo primário e não tem
nada a ver com a vitamina D tá o
paratormônio ele atua aumentando a
liberação de cálcio dos ossos e também
ele aumenta a reabsorção nos rins
então o excesso paratormônio pode levar
a problemas tanto nos ossos quanto nos
INSS quando a pessoa tem a deficiência
de vitamina D de dado que é um cofator
fundamental na absorção intestinal de
cálcio essa falta vai reduzir a
disponibilidade de cálcio no sangue vai
cair o cálcio no sangue e isso vai
desencadear a secreção do paratormônio
para normalizar os níveis de cálcio no
sangue então o paratormônio na maioria
das vezes ele pode ser utilizado como
marcador indireto de deficiência de
vitamina D mas tem que ser avaliado isso
como um todo ele pode aumentar como eu
falei em outras situações como
hiperparatiroidismo que eu acabei de
explicar o hiperparatiroidismo primário
ou mesmo a insistência renal pode
aumentar o
pth então quanto você tomar sol cada uma
hora de sol por dia mais ou menos vai te
produzir 10.000 unidades de vitamina D
né até o limite mais ou menos de 30
Depende da pessoa né da pele Mas pode
chegar até mais de 30.000 unidades de
vitamina D por dia dependendo do tempo
de exposição solar e isso vai eh
controlar o paratormônio vai deixar o
paratormônio tendendo para baixo
tá doutor nesse link que não abri ainda
é compartilhado a informação de que se
ao desconfiar de um
infarto a pessoa tomaria 200 mg de ácido
salicílico 150 MG de clopidogrel e que
isso poderia reduzir o risco de morte em
42% faz sentido todo sentido tá essa
estatística Eu precisaria checar a
origem dela mas ela é bem coerente essa
estatística esse procedimento pode
realmente ser feito Poder pode mas quem
que vai ter clopidogrel na mão assim
fácil né aspirina até tudo bem né que é
uma coisa mais fácil de achar e de
comprar a não ser que seja uma pessoa
que já tem essa esse risco né de
infartar e resolve comprar o clopidogrel
perdão eh mas o cidrão não que é o tipo
de remédio você tem assim sobrando na
gaveta da de casa né as muita gente
ainda usa o as como antitérmico né para
baixar febre de criança não é mais
tão comum como era ano passado mas ainda
tem muita gente que usa o as infantil
então tomar dois as infantil já dá 200
mg Mas o clopidogrel que eu acho meio né
fora da realidade ter isso aí à mão
né mas a pergunta se esse procedimento
poderia ser feito diria que sim tá mas
eu tenho uma outra proposta né em vez de
fazer isso por que não tomar Nat kinas
com
picnogenol todos os dias né faz muito
mais sentido no meu ponto de vista para
prevenção de infarto do que simplesmente
ficar deixando esses remédios aí na
gaveta e para reduzir 42% o risco de
morte né a gente quer reduzir o risco de
morte por infarto pelo menos em 100% Se
for possível né Lógico que a pessoa vai
morrer um dia mas
se puder não ser de infarto melhor ainda
né
então mas existe sim essa abordagem que
você tá falando tá ela é factível Ela
faz
sentido como é que atua eh essa
combinação aí eles são antiagregantes
plaquetários eles vão impedir a fama de
coágulos que vão obstruir as coronárias
agora eu acho que isso faz mais sentido
para pessoas que já têm esses remédios
na mão às vezes a pessoa já tomou o
clopidogrel ou toma o clopidogrel
e só aumenta a dose temporariamente
porque tá com suspeita de
infartar Mas o que eu faria é se seu pai
tem esse risco aumentado de
eh de infarto eu daria natoquinase
piquin genal para esse cara para sempre
tá para tomar para sempre
Lembrando que aspirina não deve ser
utilizado em pessoas que têm histórico
aí de úlcera gástrica úlcera endod denal
e que tem alergia Esses medicamentos
Ok mas é sim uma conduta totalmente
viável isso tá falando aí se você tiver
Os dois remédios na mão e se estiver
suspeitando de infarto Tá mas de novo
utilize Nat kinas
e picnogenol 200 mg de cada por dia sem
parar controle a pressão arterial
controle o peso controle os lipídeos do
sangue e use ômega-3 tem uma alimentação
limpa uma alimentação
antiinflamatória faça atividade física
regular né usa a vitamina K2 também vai
controlar a deposição de cálcio nas
artérias utiliza a vitamina C que também
tem ação de saúde
endial com enema Q1 também ajuda tá
bom quantos ovos de codorna um adulto de
52 kg pode comer ao
dia que pergunta curiosa
né como é que seria o critério pra gente
definir quantos ovos de dorna um adulto
deve comer porque assim eu já ouvi falar
que tem aí pessoas
fisiculturista que
come 100 ovos por dia né se você fala a
pessoa não acredita né acha que é
mentira
então mas nunca me fizeram essa pergunta
do di codona eu posso dizer para você
que ovo de galinha para 99% das pessoas
C ovos por dia é totalmente Seguro tá
agora
codorna aí você me pegou viu vamos
analisar
aqui em termos de saúde
metabólica Vamos considerar aqui que
cada ovo de codona corresponde sei
lá quantos ovos de codona vai completar
um ovo de galinha
Acho que uns cinco né alvo de codona
mais ou
menos enquanto que um ovo comum vai dar
uns 10 g 15 g de proteína
e eu acho que o ovo de codola vai ser
mais ou menos um démo disso daí vai dar
1,2
G Então vou chutar aqui tá porque eu não
tenho essa informação super Clara na
literatura mas eu vou dizer para você
que eu acho que vamos colocar 25 Ovos de
codorna aí a não ser que a pessoa tenha
um problema muito sério com colesterol
eu não acredito que ovo seja uma fonte
de colesterol tão importante assim
apesar de ser rico em colesterol 80% do
colesterol do organismo produzido pelo
corpo não é na
alimentação vamos dizer que se a pessoa
não tem uma epidemia importante daria
para comer uns 25 ovos de Mas isso é um
educated guest tá como fala o americano
é um chute educado Tá bom mas a pergunta
é muito curiosa sim
né Eu acho que essa foi a última
pergunta e foi da Maria
Helena vamos ver a a
manifestações ao
vivo
eh tem aqui pergunta do Eliseu
Qual é o tipo de magnésio é bom para
enxaqueca praticamente todos
Eliseu treonato ele tem a vantagem
passar melhor a barreira em Mata
encefálica mas eu diria que
o magnésio dimalato também é bom o
magnésio taurato também é bom magnésio
glicina também é
bom não vejo
porque não utilizar essa somma de
magnésio
também é verdade que a vantagem de tomar
suplemento cúrcuma sem piperina é ter um
efeito maior na mucose intestinal sim é
verdade tem até um produto no Mercado
Chama cubo é de curcumina e de bosua né
cubo que não tem piperina e não tem
outro tipo de facilitador
de absorção justamente para agir a nível
ind intestinal tá então é verdade sim
tomar floral de canela é bom para
espantar mosquito Ah então ISO não é
pergunta não isso é uma dica floral de
canela sério
Denise não conhecia isso
não mas floral não é que nem homeopatia
que é super super diluído né Será que
vai funcionar
como você já testou isso aí Denise você
mesma porque porque assim pensando em
termos de porque H opatia tudo é muito
diluído né extremamente diluído Será que
o mosquito ia perceber a molécula da
canela no meio da meio curioso isso aqui
doutor para fungo na unha além de
clotrimazol tópico algo mais a ser usado
tem terbinafina tópica também quanto
tempo tem os óleos essenciais também
você pode usar óleo essencial de
ã de orégano de capim limão
de o titri Né que é o melaleuca eles tê
ação de fungica quanto tempo para ficar
totalmente livre do Fungo meses viu
Fernando meses pode durar até mais de um
ano em alguns
casos o grande problema dos agrotóxicos
hoje em dia que não tem marcadores Como
assim marcadores Elise eu marcador do
quê Não entendi a pergunta a marcador de
exame de sangue você fala não tem sim é
o problema é
que existe exames metabolômica né de de
que você pode fazer e tem o o exame
também de urina que dá para fazer tá e o
problema é que não tão largamente
disponíveis e o plano de saúde não cobre
e geralmente são feitos fora do
Brasil uma pessoa intoxicada gravemente
com agrotóxicos muda de pensamento
constantemente tem um pensamento
fragment entado pode acontecer sim
tá certo Fernando mas a você tá falando
de comprar né o eu entendi a tua tua
lógica aqui o cara que já tem suspeita
de
infarto ou de doença coronariana o cara
já comprar idrogel e o as deixa guardado
é mas eu acho que faz mais sentido tomar
nainas picnogenol do que ficar esperando
o cara se lascar né entendeu Mas não tá
errado não como eu expliquei na na
resposta além de natoquinase
picnogenol uso de Aspirina 100 mg se a
pessoa não tiver contraindicação pode
usar mas muita gente tem problema de
sangramento por conta da Aspirina
tá mas se o risco for maior do o risco
de infartar for o risco maior do que D
sangramento intestinal eu usaria assim
tá suplemento de áo protege 100% não tem
100% em medicina el esquece o número
100% e 0% em medicina tá não existe
esses dois números em medicina
suplemento áo protege 100% dos efeitos
negativos dos agrotóxicos Lógico que não
Eliseu Qual é o seu conceito sobre
medicina Biofa não sei o que que é não
sei o que que é
Eliseu Sim estou usando florais agora
ajudam a dormir melhor do que medicação
que bom
fico feliz então tá que tá funcionando
mas eu fiquei curioso em relação a
ser repelente né você tem experiência
deles como repelente se você puder
responder arroz orgânico tem menos
arsênico que o comum Teoricamente era
para ter menos
tá mas o arsênico não necessariamente
vem só do agrotóxico ele pode vir do
próprio solo
contaminado por outras fontes que não
sejam
necessariamente agrotóxico Então se o
arroz orgânico foi plantado no lugar
errado pode ter arsênico sim
tá não é nenhum problema até comentei aí
o são são agentes antifúngicos
eh que você pode utilizar não tem
problema de usar junto
não na imagem que mostrei lá no grupo
disz que o suplemento própolis Verde
made Green
Caps são 50% Esse 50% é extrato seco
mesmo não sei elizu você faz umas
perguntas para mim às vezes que você tem
que falar com o fabricante né pedir para
ele o laudo técnico laudo do produto tá
toda vez que vocês tiverem dúvida assim
de Ah será que esse produto tem eh
concentração x y z pede o laudo técnico
pro fabricante Se ele não quiser dar
porque é suspeito tá beleza eu não tenho
um laboratório de química em casa ou no
consultório para saber
E se esses produtos são isso que eles
dizem tá e a gente muitas vezes aprende
na na porrada né usando o produto e aí a
gente vê na prática mas eu não tem como
eu te falar que é 50% quem tem que
provar isso na verdade é o laboratório
que trabalha com essa empresa não é o
usuário ou médico que tem que isso
né essa informação que a gente obtém é
do próprio fabricante Então quem tem que
provar é o fabricante entende
elizu Boa pergunta Fernando em termos de
eficácia O
antifungico químico ele vai ser mais
potente tá só que ele vai ter muito mais
efeito colateral E então eu posso te
responder essa pergunta te dizendo que
que na média o clotrimazol vai ser mais
eficaz do que o óleo essencial porém se
a pessoa tiver paciência de usar mais
tempo óleo essencial ele vai ser muito
mais suave no organismo
tá deixa eu ver se eu pulei alguma
pergunta aqui
ah eu já aumentei a fonte aqui
casteliana agora Acho que tá dando para
ler agora né Você mandou isso aqui tem
já quase uma hora né desculpa que eu não
ter visto
antes
[Música]
Ah eu acho que respondi
tudo eu não consegui separar artigo mas
eu vou dar uma achada aqui
no a gente pode discutir algum artigo
aqui em tempo real
enquanto eu procuro o artigo aqui vocês
podem mandar outras perguntas
também Olha só que coisa engraçada que
eu achei aqui esse aqui a gente vai ter
que discutir isso
aqui é um artigo falando que que xingar
acho que xingar no sentido de ficar
gritando
eh sabe que pessoa que fala na atividade
física né eu tô entendendo que esse que
é o significado aqui desse artigo
falando em cursing cursing em inglês é
eh xingar ou qual aquela palavra mais
chique para xingamento
é blasfemar algo assim né não sei se é
isso blasfemar mas algo assim entendeu
entendeu então esse artigo tá falando
aqui que você fazer lá o xingamento
entre aspas né durante o exercício
físico ajuda a melhorar o desempenho
como é que esses caras tiveram essa
ideia meu como é que foi
isso como é que foi
isso bem vamos lá deixa eu só preparar o
material aqui para divulgar para vocês
esse artigo interessante
ah mas tem outras perguntas aqui
primeiro também diz na embalagem que um
comprimido de suplemento equivale a 160
gotas de um própolis Verde tradicional
não sei elu pede o laudo químico pros
cara na imagem diz que a quantidade de
artepel c é 30 mg é boa dose sim se for
verdade é a
dose pode tomar vinagre de maçã orgânico
junto com própolis pode Manuel Pode
sim bem vamos ao artigo né segundo esse
artigo soltar um palavrão né no meio de
um exercício difícil poderia melhorar a
performance então é um estudo recente
que analisou cinco ensaios clínicos e
chegou a uma conclusão surpreendente
xingar Enquanto você se exercita poderia
aumentar força e resistência Mas por que
acontece
isso vamos tentar entender isso
agora então esse estudo que eu tô
comentando né na verdade foi mais de um
estudo ele foi realizado foram
realizados em diferentes contextos de
exercício e os resultados foram
consistentes em todas as cinco pesquisas
analisadas em conjunto Então foi uma
metanálise os participantes que xingaram
enquanto se exercitavam apresentaram o
melhor desempenho físico em comparação
àqueles que não o fizeram então entre os
exercícios avaliados estavam teste de
força de preensão número de flexões até
exaustão e tempo de resistência em
pranchas e agachamento
isométrico os resultados mostraram um
aumento médio de 7 a
2% na performance de quem usou palavrões
eu não faço palavrão na atividade física
mas eu faço uns barulhin tá não sei se
meus barulhin Estão valendo como é o
caso aqui desse estudo agora como é que
seria palavrão filha da [ __ ] se lá fal
assim isso que eu tô achando engraçado
nesse estudo aqui mas como foi feito
esse teste nos grupos que podiam xingar
os participantes eram incentivados a
dizer palavras que
usariam ao bater o dedinho na quina do
móvel já no grupo de controle eles
repetiam palavras neutras como mesa ou
palavras com sons similares mas sem
carga emocional e os palavrões levaram
vantagem em todas as comparações
caramba imagina se isso pega nas
academias
né Então as hipóteses que os
pesquisadores levantaram para explicar
essa bizarrice
a primeira delas é o arousal arousal
psicológico né ou seja o
aumento do Estado de alerta e excitação
mental causado pelo
palavrão isso poderia levar a motivação
reduzir a inibição permitindo que a
pessoa se esforçasse Mais Além disso
existe a teoria do alívio da dor onde
xingar poderia atuar como um anestésico
natural aumentando a tolerância ao
exercício físico
estudos anteriores mostraram que o uso
de palavrões
aumentaria a capacidade de suportar dor
Intensa como segurar a mão em água
gelada por mais
tempo e não para por aí outra explicação
possível que os palavrões ajudam a
reduzir a inibição permitindo que os
participantes se soltem mais e expresse
o potencial máximo Então essa
desinibição
poderia influenciar a maneira como o
cérebro processa o esforço e fadiga
resultando em melhor desempenho físico
porém há limitações quatro dos cinco os
estudos da metanálise foram conduzidos
por o mesmo pesquisador O que significa
que pode ter um viés aí né então tem que
tomar cuidado porque eu acho que o cara
é tarado em
xingamento na atividade física né porque
o cara fez quatro estudos só disso né
então nós Precisamos de mais pesquisas
Independentes para fortalecer essas
conclusões
e os resultados no momento sugerem que
xingar pode ser uma ferramenta poderosa
para quem quer melhorar desempenho nos
treinos brincadeira
né agora queria saber que diabo de
palavrão é esse que eles estão falando
né não Qual que é a palavra exata né se
é palavrão cabeludo se não
é é verdadeiro que arroz negro aumenta
as células tronco não sei
Nara não
sei não nunca vi essa informação em
lugar nenhum
Ah como é que é se a marca mantém a
padronização ao longo do tempo tempo
como assim O
Eliseu Ou eles vão diminuindo a
quantidade de substâncias Por que que
vão diminuiriam a quantidade de
substância Não entendi aqui isso não áo
protege dos efeitos negativos dos
agrotóxicos não Eliseu não é eficaz para
isso ele pode ajudar a melhorar o detox
do fígado que o áo Tem sim substâncias
sulfuradas né que tem enxofre que vão
ajudar na taa que vão ajudar no detox
mas não é que vai ser uma solução
definitiva para isso não
tá olha a Denise aqui se manifestando
Tony Robins né o famosíssimo Coach né o
mais famoso do mundo usa xingamentos em
seus treinos para dar um up legal Denise
saber disso não obrigado pela
contribuição bem pessoal estamos com uma
hora de lá
Eu acho que já dá pra gente encerrar
né agradeço muito aí a participação de
vocês Eliseu começa a Mandar e-mail pras
empresas e pede o laudo químico deles tá
é assim que se faz as coisas
beleza então nós nos vemos semana que
vem para mais uma live até lá um grande
abraço um beijo no coração de
vocês até a próxima obrigado Eloí pelo
comentário carinhoso tchau tchau